the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody it is already time for
round seven of the 2022 spring chess
classic i am grand master alejandra
ramirez here at the studio in saint
louis with my good friend grandmaster
christian curilla as we're ready to take
on the last third of the tournament
alejandro always a pleasure to be here
in the beautiful studio here at the
saint louis chess club doing commentary
on this exciting games these players
have given us so much excitement for the
past seven days absolutely and tell us a
little bit about how the tournament is
going who's running away with it and who
surprised you well let's look at the
standings we're going to start with the
standings in group a in a poor position
we have ray robson who is having an
amazing event he drew yesterday's game
and is leading with four and a half out
of six tied for second position is sam
savion and ilya nishnik aram hakobian in
seoul fourth position he lost yesterday
against a surging sam savion he has
three and a half points and tied for
fifth position we have a pack of three
wolves jeffrey shawn darius virg and
hans nemo yeah and alex lunderman a
little bit lockless in the tournament
but finds himself with two points after
finally winning a game uh misha antipov
however scores the third draw of the
tournament moves to one and a half on
kamil dragoon uh he was the luckless
victim of london man yesterday and finds
himself also with one and a half let's
take a look at group b
in which chris repki is the clear leader
oh absolutely chris is just simply
dominating the event so far yesterday he
escaped with a draw nevertheless he was
on the back foot against the experienced
el shawn muradiabadi but he managed to
salvage a draw in a second position is a
surging abhimanyu mishra he won four
games in a row alejandro that is an
amazing result for the youngest grand
master in history christopher you lost
his game yesterday and is he in seoul
third position with three and a half
points el shadmore adiabatic and sam
kanin tied for fourth position with
fifty percent
right and robert hungaski who is the
rating favorite of the tournament a
little lucky yesterday to actually score
that full point against somebody else
that has fifty percent titus tramavichus
for a completely winning position titus
just played the wrong move order ended
up down a piece wasn't able to find his
stride meanwhile we have jj ali morandi
armada mikhail and harshid raja with his
first win of the tournament joining
there at two points the tournament
format is very simple we have two ten
player round robins for you it's a
classical chess here at the saint louis
chess club 90 minutes for 40 moves an
extra 30 minutes for the remainder of
the game and we have a 30 second
increment from move one also the players
are not allowed to mutually agree to a
draw in less than 40 moves this is going
to ensure that we're going to have a
very combative event here at the spring
chess classic and how about the schedule
alejandro the schedule is also simple
it's one round a day here at the st
louis chess club we start at 1 pm every
day except for round number nine that is
the last round we start two hours early
not only over the board but also here in
the commentary booth as we will start
our commentary at 1 30 pm central as
opposed to the usual 3 30 p.m and don't
forget guys join the discussion on
social media you can actually reach us
on twitter where we are very active
we're going to see your questions if you
send them to
spring chess classic also this broadcast
is on youtube but also on twitch tell us
a little bit about that alejandro
absolutely for every 75 that we receive
in donations subs bits it doesn't have
to be one donation specifically we can
add them up uh for 75 we're able to give
a kid a child a student here a full
semester of chess programming that means
that they're going to be able to attend
lectures become better chess players
understand the game and remember this is
an important stepping stone all the way
from the scholastic level to the super
elite we have it all here at the same
lewis chess club but we couldn't do it
without your help we are in round number
seven so let's take a look at the
pairings we're going to start with a
group a and camille dragoon is playing
against sam sevi and jeffrey shong uh
has not had the form that he usually has
in the spring classics playing against
alex london actually that game has
already finished in a draw uh mikhail
antipa ice playing against hans demon
darius schwartz playing against nick
that would really be a candidate for
game of the day if we didn't have this
great matchup between aram hakobian who
goes to webster university and ray
robson who's been leading the tournament
playing scintillating chess taking
advantage of all these opportunities
that his opponent are giving him
particularly i can remember the game
against misha and tipoff where we just
pretty much gave the game up for a draw
and out of nowhere he was able to find
some pressure put his opponent in some
trouble and ended up converting that
position meanwhile in group b we have
the matchups of harshid raja versus sam
hanin abimanu mishra the youngest
grandmaster in uh not only the event but
the entire world is playing against el
shawn morgan body titus drama vicious is
playing as armin meghalian jj ali
marandi playing against robert kungaski
in a really fun game so far we'll
probably take a look at that one quickly
but we have to start with the game of
the leader chris rafka has been
scintillating he was able to salvage
half a point yesterday in a completely
lost position against alcian and must
find some confidence there he's playing
against christopher yu who certainly is
vying for first place but being hit with
a loss yesterday could not have felt
good christian tell us where do these
two players stand right now well i have
to tell you alejandro this battle is as
exciting as it can get the battle
between chris repka and christopher you
this is in group number b the clash of
the titans and chris uh repc started off
with knight to f3 we've seen him um
start with d4 and c4 but his main weapon
is the ratty with knight to f3 g3 bishop
to g2 fiance the bishop and keeping a
lot of flexibility in his position as
white from the early onstage knight to
f3 d5 g3 c5 very aggressive approach by
christopher yu we've seen christopher
actually in general after knight to f3
he tends to respond with the move knight
to f6 he delays this idea of d5
potentially keeping d6 and the type of
kings indian structures
in his pocket but in this instance he
decides to go directly with d5 a very
direct approach g3 c5 taking the center
as soon as possible bishop to g2 knight
to f6 castle e6 this is a very typical
approach nowadays of course white can uh
try to go with an immediate c4 but
that's going to allow black to play the
move a d4 and create that this reverse
benoni type of structures let's see how
white decided to play b3 that's another
approach of course as i was mentioning
earlier white has a lot of flexibility
in this position b3 is one of the ways
in which you can play c4 is another one
d4 is also a move in the position and
try to play some sort of a reversed
groove nevertheless if you want to get
the reverse grunfeld you should probably
wait for black to develop the knight to
c6 so for example if uh white plays this
move b3 and then knight to c6 would come
on the board now d4 is an option because
whenever uh we see this exchange on the
board black in general without the
knight on c6 would be very happy to see
this move on the board targeting the
knight on d4 and if white doesn't have
this exchange available knight takes c6
then his position becomes worse he has
to retreat with the knight that's not
good news so instead of that
black played the move bishop to e7 once
again preparing uh to meet this d4 with
c takes d4 and now we see bishop to b2
castle
c4 finally uh we're seeing a challenge
for the pawn structure here in the
center c4 d4 e3 knight to c6 and now we
have those type of
reverse benoni structures rook to e1
bishop to c5 now bishop to c5 is clearly
aimed at connecting the pawn structure
with this move e5 and taking even more
control in the center that's why
immediately white plays the move knight
to e5 stopping that knight takes e5 rook
takes c5 queen to d6 and now the battle
is all about this important square on b5
but also about this expansion in the
center that black wants to see on the
board with the move e5 and this is
exactly why we see this rook planted in
the center but also supported by the
pawn on f4
and now we see
this position
all the way into this position
a lot of things have happened but we
have a lot of games also to keep an eye
on right now it seems like the position
has simplified a little bit we've seen
that e5 come on the board we see an
exchange on b5 that night white knight
landed on b5 it was immediately chopped
off the board e5 is on the board and
right now it seems like black has more
squares for his pieces this knight is
going to land either on f2 if you're not
going to pay attention but most likely
on e3 this is a beautiful outpost and we
see that this is what uh knights love to
have outposts especially in your
opponent's camp and this is past the
midline only three a very dangerous
square for the night not only that but
this knight on g4 is going to support a
potential attack via the sixth rank this
queen is
ready to jump to h6 and create an
immediate check mating threat it seems
like right now black is in full control
of the game and maybe chris rebka is
going to lose his first game in this
event yeah i'm very familiar with this
kind of structure especially because i
play them so often with the white pieces
from a different move order this kind of
ready type of situations but it feels
that everything went wrong for him and
if we can pull out
this game actually i was going to put up
another but i want to go back to that
position of chris redka uh there's a
couple of things that look really nice
for white but there's a couple of
problems that you run into in this
particular structure when you misplace
your pieces this bishop on b2 sometimes
is really good and sometimes it's really
bad and in this case it's just an awful
piece you can see that it is attacking
the pawn on d4 but it's such an easy
pawn to defend and the bishop is
actually in the middle of all of the
pieces it's not you're i'm not able to
really coordinate my rooks i probably
want to ha i have to play the move
bishop c1 at some point but it's it's
not an easy move to make it is a
backwards move it doesn't really
uh contribute to the position that much
and even in a scenario where the knight
comes to e3 it's not really clear that
you want to chop it off with your bishop
and give black a powerful pass pawn on
the e3 square i wanted to go very
quickly around group b because i thought
this was a very funny opening uh this is
actually a legit line uh which ali
marande is using in the in against
uh this is the scandinavian uh teams
candy for all those uh twitch people uh
take stakes knight c3 and of course
queen d a queen d6 has been all the rage
but queen a5 is still the main line and
the move b4 is actually a move
i i think at some point it started uh
this is your student this is my student
did you teach him this move b4 no no no
this is this is general culture at san
luis university this is well known
i think this started off um
interestingly as a uh as a pre-move win
on bullet games on icc
where they actually played the move
before because you play something else
randomly with black pre-moving and then
you take on a5 but then people realized
and put it on some real engines and they
thought actually this is not so bad and
some old games propped up and people
realized oh this actually been an idea
forever and it revived it revived at
some point and it's not it's not so bad
uh yes you do give up a pawn seemingly
for free you do have this b file open um
is the b file really worth a pawn
probably not but you do keep kicking the
queen around and in some practical point
of view this is uh really really
unpleasant for
black to play that being said
it is a pawn i think objectively black
is supposed to be better but
it's it's easy to lose your path in this
position especially if you don't know
what you're doing and i have the feeling
that jj uh smelled the fish with
hongoski playing this candy they didn't
want to play a solid position and just
kind of went for it and i'm going to
just fast forward a little bit uh to poo
to prove more or less the
trouble that black can run into this us
uh if not obviously prep is very close
to preparation uh white sacrifice is a
second pawn but now the move bishop b2
takes on h8 is quite a real threat
because whenever you interpose with this
check i have bishop c3
and that's all good so this is not gonna
be a this is gonna be a little
fun for white to play and you have the
initiative you have the bishop coming to
b2 the queen on e5 is the only developed
piece that black has and a lot of
factors that the computers don't care
about
actually are very difficult to play with
here so after f6 we're i'm just going to
speed through to what actually happened
in the game
we eventually got to this position
and
it feels to me that black is still very
far from
completing any kind of development i'm a
little curious about the move knight of
two but still does not enjoy this rook
on h8 is stuck
if anybody's better it has to be white i
just don't know how much better he is
like how much pressure you can put on
this position well let's try to figure
out some variations on the 100 yeah this
started with knight f4
yeah i think knight f4 is the most
logical move it attacks the queen and it
moves the knight out of the defense the
main goal of black's position right now
is to get the knight to h6 probably
landing on f7 to keep a defensive uh
post right and then connect the rooks
and
i'm still two pawns up right so if you
don't do anything before i can manage to
do those two moves i will be uh probably
in a winning position as black
yeah i agree with you so time is of the
essence here for jj i think the move the
knight f4 is very nice it attacks the
queen so i do have to move it i cannot
take on e7 it's still defended i could
play something like queen e4 queen c4
i'm not really sure which way i'm
leaning
maybe maybe even e4 maybe on c4 the
reason i didn't necessarily want to put
it on c4 is because b5 might be a tempo
but on the other hand what i like about
moving b5 i can take with the roof oh
that's a very good point christian sorry
for missing that yeah yeah b5 i just i
just take that the queen is pinned
that's why i put the queen on c4 because
i'm anticipating a knight potentially
landing on d5 and i want to have some
ideas of maybe putting the rook on d1
and taking on d5 i don't know if it
works of course this is just fantasy at
this point and maybe you have to leave
that c4 square free for the pawn to
actually target the knight coming to d5
right there's a lot of considerations
specific considerations that go into
this position the knight comes to f4 and
it's already on f4 on the board as far
as i can it is yes and the queen
actually has a lot of squares and it
almost feels that every single one of
them comes with some kind of hindrance
if you put on it on c4 as you mentioned
christian you don't have the push c4
kicking out the
knight that we expect will land on d5
you put it on anywhere on the d file you
have to watch out for a tempo on d8 on
f1 it's kind of passive and the reason
that i didn't necessarily want to put it
on e4 which is probably the most logical
square is that i'm not i'm not attacking
e1 with the rook
so black could entertain the idea of
going knight h6
sacrificing this pawn on e7 and trying
to get this rook into the game but i'm
getting too many points right but the
problem is that yeah you
once you take and take and you kind of
have to cover you don't actually finish
your development this rook takes on b7
you have this horrible pin on the
seventh and material is just even right
i have gained enough pawns that's the
last material that's the problem yeah
and strategically you're still losing
it's not
black actually hasn't fixed some of the
more serious problems i think not only
strategically but you're losing by force
because whatever you put on f8 i'm going
to go rook to d7 yeah rick designer once
i think rookie four also one okay yeah
this is always a check so it doesn't
really matter what i double attack
double attack actually this one might
not win because of this
right yeah uh or b8 or rugby it also
works yeah yeah so but the movie rook d7
is suggested by christian uh attacking
this rook and i take on f7 it's gonna be
chuck uh seems to finish off the game so
knight f4 we expect the move queen e4
now that we analyzed it for two seconds
and after queen to e4 i'm going to play
this move e5
yeah this is probably the only try right
yes again i i just want to get knight to
h6 on the board
i will be very happy if i manage to do
that
so how do you start why how do i
actually continue this attack that is a
good question i mean
i know that jj is starting to calculate
stuff like bishop d6 stage
but i i think the king's very safe on f8
here so i don't think this works at all
so
i'm not sure actually how do you
continue in this position
okay so maybe queen e4 is not the right
move yeah but it is the most logical
right it is i don't like i really like
the queen there okay i have an idea
uh-huh what if you go
queen to d2
yeah quindi2 is also quite
quite nice right you do manage to attack
a7 with the rook if you go e5 then maybe
bishop to d6 yes but what we have to
calculate in this position is what
happens if you first uh play the move
rook d8 because it is a nasty tempo here
against the queen
and actually alejandro can we show that
bishop to d6 because i think it's quite
important yes yes
um right now queen to d7 first of all
doesn't work because i have the
discovery check with bishop to f8 ah
that's even that's even better than rook
takes e5 but that was my yes exactly
rook take c5 is uh the critical point
with this bishop to d6 because after
queen to f7 it looks like you're
defending absolutely everything but rook
takes c5 and i think i'm breaking
through
yeah i think this starts to collapse for
black you see this king is a little bit
too weak i'm going to pick up the next
move
no matter what you do like knight f6
f4 yeah and i'm going to build up the
pressure i am no longer down too much
material it's only an exchange
and i feel that the threats come uh too
quickly yeah the king is just too weak
right in general i i don't i don't see
what you can do about it it seems like a
big moment right now for jj well you
know you know jj in big moments he just
doesn't think and
he plays them with queen c4 almost
immediately that's the style of players
right you see a lot of different
personalities in this type of
tournaments i think you get used to the
top players
you understand and analyze
a lot of these things
but once you reach the lower 2500s 2600s
you can see a lot more style come out i
feel that sometimes they don't play as
correctly they they let their style
shine a little bit more and you can see
it here with jj right he plays very fast
and this wild complications doesn't
really like to sit down and calculate
which one is the most precise move
because he also understands the
practicality of making a move and making
your opponent think well also let's uh
look at the clocks right yeah it seems
like kungaski is down to his last six
minutes
this is not a fun position to play
much less on six minutes no and queen c4
does have a clear threat and that is of
course you probably will want to go
something like 95 as we were mentioning
but that knight from f2 and that's why i
think he played this move knight to f2
he wants to go back
yeah
i'm not sure before d3 but one of these
two squares and then to c fun and then
if i manage to land on e6 obviously
that's going to have devastating
consequences so you have to defend
against that but do you play b6 which
weakens your pawn structure even more
and then maybe i can invade with the
rook uh on e6 yeah this looks very ugly
honestly this is this looks
very very ugly for
especially with less than six minutes on
the clock yeah i see so to be honest i
think this looks ugly even without
without the time pressure but with the
time pressure i'm not really sure how
he's planning to hold this let's go
around group b real quick just to see
what's going on
i feel we always start with group b and
perhaps we shouldn't but
sam honey in here must be
either
if
if
if this pawn on f7 wasn't so weak i
would say that he is almost winning
because he is up a pawn
but
there might be some tactics in the
position i have to calculate what
happens on bishop d4
then there's like what what does happen
after bishop d4 that attacks this rook
it attacks this knight the knight is
holding on to the bishop
uh i want to go very quickly through the
game so i'm going to turn on the engine
so i don't mess this up no no the engine
does say black is winning
precisely because of this move bishop d4
it's more or less key it's also an
obvious move uh you hit the rook and you
hit the bishop and it forces this rook
on a7 to an awkward square on d7 where i
can later hit it with my own rook on b5
there's a discovery on this square so i
expect before attacking this the rule
comes to d7 defending that so that when
i chop this knight the bishop on d5 is
defended but here i can start thinking
of trading pieces with rook c5 or move
the rook somewhere and the bishop will
be attacking the rook in many variations
i'm actually a little surprised about
the move rook c1 here
it feels like the move rook d1 was more
or less necessary after which white i
think is still in the game rook where do
you
having a tough day here having a tough
day
all right uh roxy won the actually it's
the only uh movie yeah that's the only
move you can place it on uh meanwhile
titus tarmavichus
i see a checkmate in two moves coming
yeah this is a thread yeah bishop d3 is
a big threat so you have to be paying a
lot of attention to that yeah let me
count the material first uh white is up
a pawn
and does have the better structure but
black has the pair of bishops and a
strong initiative against this king
which which i think is slightly weaker
than this one not not to say that the
king on jade is doing
is having a field day but
but this will come down to calculation
as we mentioned the move let's just put
some move on the board uh
bishop d3 check is a huge threat because
now the queen and the bishop are
connected on the b2 square and they'll
be checking the next move
no matter how you respond to this check
so you have to do something and the
first instinct that i have is to start
stick something on e5 like the bishop
but then i see that f2 is hanging and
i'm wondering if i should defend it
first no i i don't think you can defend
it that easily i thought about rogue d2
actually defense both uh here and here
yeah rook d2 makes some sense but now
rook d8 yeah coming with tempo i i am
getting worried about some stuff i'm not
sure which rook but rook d8 is kind of
clever to play the other one a rook that
one because this is not a check so i
still have bishop d3
that being said
uh i'm not really sure what you gain if
i play this but you should hold the
bishop d3 check here still bishop the
exhibition d3 because now i have to take
with the rook i cannot take with the
queen because i lose it but taking with
the rook leads into checkmate so first
for that reason perhaps is that you have
to stick something on e5 as mentioned
earlier uh which did it and he did and
titus decides to deny that he has to
stick there i would have probably given
some preference to the bishop unless
there were some tactical issues but
perhaps there were uh the knight on e5
doesn't get rid of the pair of bishops
right now but that is a very good
question why not bishop e5 yeah bishop
e5 looks more logical right i'm not
going that crazy today no no no i think
bcb5 makes a lot of sense i think he was
maybe afraid of bishop to c6 this is the
only thing that this is the only reason
you wouldn't play this move right yeah
and perhaps there's some lines in which
this bishop is lost
actually it's not even so easy to
retreat the queen that's the problem
yeah this queen doesn't have a lot of
great squares
i don't want to go back to u1 but on e2
sometimes it gets tempo'd right this is
a tempo against the queen and
i have to take with the pawn and at the
very least black is not worse here is
probably just much better actually with
some threats yeah black white has some
counter play perhaps uh better is an
exaggeration but black would have no
problems
and we do see i i believe bishop maybe
bishop takes c5
uh there was a move i know or queen
takes f2
yeah yeah so the melee here rages on
it's difficult to evaluate but
the instinct is the bishops are good
bishop's good
knight's not so good open position rook
to d2 was played which makes a lot of
sense makes a lot of sense you have to
play rogue two you cannot live with the
queen on f on f 2 and you cannot play
rook f1 of course because of the bishop
on b5 so
the queen dropped the back
instantaneously yeah
c5
c5 right i think he put it on c5 but i'm
100 no he put it on b6 but both were
logical options i'm gonna give black a
very slight edge just because i like
bishops but not only five might be good
enough for equality
i would always take black here though
you would okay interesting yeah
it's my it's my feeling that
the lights especially because these
light squares are so weak
that i i might be able to if this bishop
gets to d5
right right i mean the game is kind of
over that's the dream the game is kind
of over and how do you get there i'm not
sure i'm also not sure what white's plan
is i mean you can go g4 g5 but even even
after that i'm not entirely sure how you
make progress so i'm a little bit on the
stuck side let me finish up the group
because we only have remaining the game
of the of the wunderkind
abhimanyu mishra
and what is going on here currently
white is up in exchange but that will
last exactly
the question is how much you're going to
get for it okay you have to defend the
rooks i don't really think it matters
very much question is which rook it
doesn't matter i think let's sure do one
of them
uh i don't i don't really have any
better move than taking so i'll take
look i see two bishops i i like it oh
okay so black is opponent black is upon
that's the only saving grace right if
white had a pawn on e4 i think we could
even start thinking about black
hammering a decisive white having a
decisive advantage because these bishops
are monstrous and this bishop not so
good that being said
since we don't have that pawn on e4
it's not
very clear to me what the evaluation of
this endgame is the main difference is
not so much that you're down upon but
this knight on f6 when it lands there
we'll actually tether something to
defending d5 for example if i start with
the move b5 and i really like the move
b5 because first of all the defense
against the immediate threat of bishop
takes a6 it takes away the c4 square for
the bishop on f1
and i actually don't like the move b5 at
all
i will take on b5 and then rook c2 yeah
i was hoping you would do this because
here i think i have knight f6
and this was kind of my point that when
the rook leaves
uh d2 i'm able to play knight f6 attack
the pawn on d5 and what if i go rook c7
yeah rook c7 i think
i think i
i interposed with the bishop sure and
bishop a7
and bishop a7 and when you're claiming
that i'm not on time
i think you're just one move away from
uh finishing your
your setup yeah cause i want to take on
d5 but unfortunately this rook will be
defended after bishop b8 and the point
is that if i move away
you take take and this important move at
the end bishop c4
pins the knight against the king and
white ends up winning because the only
way to defend it
gives up a very important bishop so
perhaps i need to be a little more
careful about this b5
i still find it like the instinctual
best move
but perhaps here i have to be a little
patient and go uh rook b7
i like that move yeah they covered it it
covers the second rank it you know i
don't have to worry about bishop a7
anymore and the question for white is
how do you maneuver around to hit this
guy
if you hit the guy you will win
but it's not so easy perhaps for this
reason you actually go not root c2 but
rook a2 and you can see kind of the
grand master process there the thought
of process right you want the open file
you see the open file you calculate a
couple of variations and then you think
actually was the rook better on a
different one and i think it's better on
a2 just for the reason that rook a5 will
actually be hitting the pawn immediately
so for example if i play rogue b7 to
guard against these threats
uh
but now there is no more that's bishop
to a7 that is very true now there is no
bishop to a7 and perhaps because of all
of these reasons that we're talking
about way back here we realized that
this rook on d2 is actually kind of
silly this rook on a1 is actually very
important we're getting somewhere now
we're getting now we now it looks like
we understand chess he gives up not the
d-rook but the a-rook so that when b5
comes if b5 comes
i can take
i can take take and i will open up the
rook
for
the seventh rank
and i think that
if b5 is not playable
yeah you have you cannot play b5 at this
you have to go a5 but that's that's
that's pretty sad that creates the
square c5 for my knight though so i'm
quite happy with that aspect that's
smooth that is true but i'm wondering if
you actually get there so king to e7
king to e7 and then i wanted to play
rook csup rook c1 control the file
try to go as quickly as possible to the
c7 square
so i'm going to defend that king to d8
and then you go king d8 the thing i
don't like about king d8 it does feel
like i'm hanging on by a thread i'm not
going to right this especially because
of this check right it's a surprising
check
and it seems that you still have one
move here i'm not sure how to evaluate
this i have the feeling this fall is
completely lost yeah i have the feeling
this falls apart somehow i haven't
figured out exactly how well i'm
paralyzed you're completely paralyzed
and i think you can just take on a5 and
then bring the king all the way to b5
yeah i actually think you win like that
you just put the do you take take with
the bishop on c6 you cannot do anything
but king eight king
e7 king e7 and this king literally
literally will march all the way to b5
take that pawn and win and you also have
to be very careful because if you do try
to uh push your pawns on the king side
with h6 g5 now you create a different
avenue for my king via the square f5 so
i will go king d3 king e4 king f5 and
then i'll pick up the kings that'll pick
up the queen's side this is completely
paralyzed this is very very bad for
maybe there's some sort of study like uh
defense disposition for black but study
like with maybe it doesn't feel like it
yeah i i don't think that black is
holding and because of this evaluation
of the few lines that we looked at it
might be the case that black is doing
very badly because if you have to play
rook a8 and give up the c file
you're in very dire straits but
you cannot give up a6 for free this is
not one of those positions where you can
give up the bond for free
uh so i really like uh abby manuel's
chances of scoring a fifth win in a row
wow amazing see what the engine says
just because we have so many games and
just says b5 equal
sure whatever b5 equal okay i don't need
to understand that i don't even know why
i turned it on
so b5 equal you take right you have to
take on b5 open up the a5 rook a7 or r5
which one do you go for you know i'm
actually scared of both
i'm not gonna lie i feel like i'm losing
against both rook a7 with the pin and
rook a5 with the uh i want to keep the
the king on f7 just because whenever
knight lands on d5 i will have this pin
bishop c4 so let's start with rook a5
knight f6 right
i guess the only move in the position or
pretty much right no but then bishop
thinks b5 i can't even take with the
rock honestly
because again it's one of those
scenarios where if you take on d5 and i
go here and you go here
you can just you can't do anything
you're so sad because you can't do
anything at the moment you push this you
lose the knight so i'm just going to
literally boom boom boom and take the
knight or bishop ace bishop a7 and
promote the pawn for free i mean
whatever it's completely winning
uh so this is actually very sad i am
very confused
the
i mean if i didn't click on the engine
we would have looked like magicians like
very smart
but apparently knight f6 so perhaps
maybe just rook b7 you actually just go
rook c8 and the engine says it's equal
and this is beyond but from a practical
perspective definitely doesn't feel
equal i mean it's not that it doesn't
feel equal it feels
lost right like you move the rook and
the pump remotes
and that's it that's the game you have a
bishop on f8 that's not participating
the knight just moved out of the queen
side
uh but engines are engines luckily these
are not engines playing and i i i don't
think i would ever go for the move b5
here
i would actually just hunker down and go
rk8 because i think b5 would lose by
force but the problem with rook a8 is
that now i get the c file yeah and you
also have two weaknesses that i can
target both of those pawns are still on
the board and that is a big problem and
i would say if it's even three
weaknesses right because uh this these
three squares d6 as well d6 square but
okay the
b5 equal is beyond my understanding all
right let's move on to group a
uh camille dragoon is playing against
sam savian this is a huge mess on the
board
uh what is the material count why does
up
one pawn
but we have a mess on the board
obviously g5 is a testing move you
cannot take on g5 because after i take
remember it's check
bishop takes g5 knight takes f3 at the
end what
knight takes f3 oh knight x-f yeah
knight takes f3 uh bishop takes e4 okay
and this is what i was trying to
calculate because you attack the rook
and you're like bishop f4 you've got
bishop f4 and so you can get that though
bishop back by taking on f3 but how is
that in game isn't that completely lost
i i never want to say completely lost
when there's two rooks on the board as
opposed to just one right one but this
is definitely not what
black ones so what is the point of g5
takes is check takes takes well it just
feels like a desperado move was this
position that bad let me let me go back
down
well he is upon down and has a horrible
position so now now you begin to
understand where the desperation comes
from
perhaps he didn't see a better move than
g5 because
yeah actually
from the position before g5 it's it's
quite obvious that white is a couple of
moves away from consolidating fully and
just taking the game i mean the bishop
if you get bishop b2 and rook d1 in
that game is over the game is over yeah
you're up a pawn you have the better
king you have the better structure of
the better bishop you have everything so
perhaps
sensing absolute panic mode sam goes
into the move g5 and queen takes g5
is definitely possible but it's not
necessary the thing is knight g2 allows
g4
and this this is what i think sam really
wants yeah he wants to uh weaken the
light squares around the king and
potentially land the knight on f3 and
then he's going to be able to find some
sort of compensation based on the fact
that the bishop on aid becomes a
complete monster so i'm going to try to
avoid that at all cost let's go queen
takes g5 i really want to exchange the
queens i want to take this game into a
technical territory yeah and i think
there's not there's no good reason not
to right then knight g2 g4 looks
complicated and this one looks like two
results the only move here is knight f3
if you don't play knight f3 here then i
don't know what this combination was
yeah you could actually consider taking
with the rook but i don't think it helps
you because instead of taking on g5
immediately i think i do take on f3
and it feels like every single one of
black uh white's pieces is
hanging in this position i i really
don't think you can defend all of them
so you actually take with the knight
first
and here we have options because i could
reverse the move order and take on f3
first
and i am actually a full rook down here
but i might also be winning a full rook
which would put me in even material and
good ground
am i missing something
because if you defend either one of your
rooks i take the other one and think the
bishop at the end the bishop itself
doesn't have anything to attack i mean
you could go bishop f4 for example
and then take on c7
but okay i do have an idea
so um let's defend the rook on
f3 so with rook bf1 yes i take on f1 i
take back
and i take here and we get into this end
game
now
i have two islands of pawns as white
the one on the queen side the one on
kingside you have four islands of pawns
so obviously from a technical
perspective white is doing great now the
question is can i target those pumps so
let's start off with rook to c3 yeah the
problem is i think black is a bit too
active in this end game i go rook c3 i
go c4 c5 yeah important move and after
look to d3 you're going to cover up with
d5 aren't you yeah i think i start
covering my pawns honestly i can start
thinking of counter play but rook d5 and
i don't think the same game is lost i do
already have a past pawn i have the
feeling that will force you to simplify
the entirety of the queen side yeah yeah
i agree
and maybe even black's pushing force
takes f3 that you found that was a a
nice blow it's easy to find moves when
you have no alternatives okay so let's
take i i feel like i have to take on f3
right you take with the knight right i
you have to take with the knight rook
takes okay right there's one to take
with the knight i don't know if it's
better to take with the rook or if it
leads to better positions but i do like
i i guess you can just simply take on f3
and take only four and go yeah you can
lie i don't think this is going to help
you very much it's just a knight instead
of the rook there yeah right you have
knight d4 but then i can just take on b1
you take on b5 i take back on b5 and
that's just going to be an equal end
game yeah we just go home after this
with the draw instantaneously so
take with the knight take with a rook on
f3
take on e4 and this is the key position
yeah this is the key right everything
really boils down to this position
very cool stuff here this g5 move by
savion
and
i by the way there is one way i see in
which at the end i could be a pawn up
now the question is how much
compensation you're going to have as
black i'm going to start with rook to e1
yeah you can go rookie one
i'll i have to take off three on f3 and
i'll push before yeah but you cannot
take on e6 and illustrate that because
remember that this bishop is hanging
uh bishop f4 actually picks up a pawn
because he will at least do that but
the thing is i go bishop d5 right yes
i think i can even go rook c5 honestly i
i'd rather you take e6 than c7 okay i'll
take only six and i go rook c2
now take on a6
and i don't really believe in this but
take as many pawns as i can yeah you
have some marginal winning chances here
right take on c7 i have two i don't but
you take on c7 here yeah this is not so
good
maybe i do have to defend against the
intrusion of the rook
bishop takes and so something happened
okay did he take on g5 i don't think he
did i don't think it took maybe because
of these variations right he's actually
played the move a4 oh wow
wow wow wow
not see that one coming that's a cool
move and you can you can find the
explanation of this move down the lines
that we went to because in so many
variations the rook on b5 is perfectly
hitting the bishop on g5 and it's also
not on a dark square let me illustrate
what i mean with that in this positions
after the move knight takes f3 rook
takes f3 rook takes f3 bishop takes e4
i would basically be winning if i can
somehow move this bishop out of g5
attacking this rook
because this bishop on e4 can only take
one of them
but
i can't i don't actually have a good way
of doing so if i play for now the g5
bishop is simply hanging
so this doesn't help
and after the move a4 instead
sam has to figure out what to do with
the rook or if he's going to sacrifice
it you could take on h4 i just don't
believe in it
um and the question is where does this
rook go right because
well we're going to let uh sam think
about this one ponder his next decision
because we do have breaking news
alejandro and that is good for you and
good for your students excellent i like
it alima randy seems to be taking over
this game and it seems like hongoski
might have blundered
this position we were mentioning he had
less than five minutes on the clock is a
very difficult position to defend
practically because you are two pawns up
but unfortunately you don't have any
development you still uh lacks safety
for your king and all your pieces are
kind of splattered all over the board so
after queen to c4 e5 came on the board
and this is already this is a very
natural move by the way but it's already
a mistake because after knight to e4 a
very good move maneuvering this knight
all the way to e6 towards z6 after i
land on c5 or on d6 i'm also putting a
lot of pressure on your weaknesses
specifically this pawn on b7 so right
now black has to be extremely careful he
played the move b6 which allows white to
go rook to d1 and now we understand the
idea of this move queen to c4 as well
you cannot plug this um open file with a
move knight to d5 because after rook to
d5 he can just simply resign on the spot
so what he did after rook to uh d1 he
played the move a b5 queen stays on the
c file once again not allowing the
knight to return into the game to return
to the center via d5 and now we have
rook to e8 rook to d6 and it seems like
the position is just falling apart
let's see in the last three four moves
well black has created more weaknesses
while white improved the position of
every single one of his pieces the
bishop became more active because right
now there's much more weaknesses with
this pawn already on b5 much more dark
square weaknesses this pawn on c6 is
going to fall there's absolutely no way
you can defend that and you still have a
lot of uh
a lot of moves to make until you can get
this rook involved into the game first
of all knight to h6 this is the problem
the pawn on f6 is going to fall and if
the pawn on f6 falls the position uh is
completely gets completely destroyed so
rook to uh d6
queen to f7 rook takes c6 i'm just
simply going to continue picking up your
weaknesses queen to d2 knight to e7
knight to d6 and to be honest oh my
goodness look at this queen
queen on g8 rook to h8 rook on e8 and
the king on g7
have you ever seen this type of setup no
no i i i think this is the first time
i'm seeing this setup i think you resign
before you got to those setups and he
did not resign he still plays on but the
position is crumbling right now
not only the okay first of all you
finally managed to connect your knights
but unfortunately everything else is
going to fall right now i'm going to go
rook to a6 pick up the pawn on a7
you just don't have enough time to
stabilize the position not only that but
you're also down a lot of material
resignable at this point hungaski is
still fighting but with 45 seconds and
counting a completely shattered position
and 10 moves to make until he reaches
the time control i think this is going
to be over in no time
yeah this looks winning for jj
topsy-turvy game of the topsy-turvy
tournament and that's honestly how he
plays chess right
he's very wild and sometimes it goes
well and sometimes it goes badly let's
take a look at the game between antipov
and niemann because this one also might
be finishing relatively quickly
uh hans niemann has had also not the
best tournament i know that he wanted to
come in winning but misha
he's not been able to find his form at
all here in st louis it's welcome to
america going
but uh this one looks completely lost
and it's very simple you count the pawns
this one is on f4
and more importantly this king activity
is
absolute destruction
and this knight is coming from f5 to g3
you can throw in a check on f2 but all
it's going to do is help me uh target
your other pawn on h3 and remember that
the moment is this pawn lands on f3
you really could just resign i mean
there's no there's no saving this
position this is game over this game
over absolutely there's no source of
counter play or anything like that in
this position and
i didn't even notice but the engine is
saying that you can also take on b5 in
certain variations no this one looks
really bad i'm not really sure where it
went so downhill it seems like the
transition to the end game
well actually this angle looks pretty
equal
where did he go wrong maybe he just got
outplayed in time pressure i think he
just did yeah he must have and that that
is the problem let's look at the time
right now he only has two minutes and 25
seconds or nine months to make right now
it's very difficult and he takes this
type of crazy decisions for example if
you back uh track a couple of moves
alejandro
d5
knight f5 c5
why yeah it's uh
why would you do this why wouldn't you
play just some normal moves such as
bishop to c3 yeah bishop c3 check is
very difficult
on b3 defend your structure right and
then just play a normal game
yeah it feels that he panicked right
that his time was running low he needed
to do something perhaps he felt some
strategical pressure because of the
weaknesses on f3 and h3
i don't know it's hard for me to say i
think after c5
one of the patterns that i've seen from
misha antipov specifically in uh this
event he's getting slightly worse
positions i'm um speaking about the game
about him and robson for from a couple
of rounds ago also with the white pieces
also in this type of structures he got a
slightly worse position completely
defendable right um it looked uh like
were just a few moves away from shaking
hands for a draw but then slowly slowly
got pushed uh backwards and then when
push came to shove to defend the
position he was just simply uh unable to
do so he did not have the patience and
this is the key word right now i feel
mishanded right now in his first
tournament on american soil is lacking
patience to defend difficult positions
yeah this really does seem to be the
case as niman is playing very quickly
he's very well aware of how winning his
position is
in this case
and i think
that we're going to see misha resigning
very soon
um
sad start here for the mizzou player but
it's just a very strong tournament and
even if you're a little bit off form i
mean
people are going to just try to beat you
from every position these are sharks and
they're definitely smelling blood right
uh no blood spilled in the darius game
against uh ilya nishnik this game
finished in a draw let me just get the
final position not really sure how they
got here probably also
um
let me just see the opening
some kind of semi sloth let me see if
there was anything particularly
interesting about it
if now we can move on
it feels that white got a little
something something but
it wasn't
it wasn't really all that interesting
yeah and the game didn't finish in the
draw so dar you're still on 50 i believe
and uh ilya still with a very good score
i think he's on plus two in this in this
tournament uh let's look at the game of
the day aram hakobian against ray robson
is still quite a fight and it's gonna be
a fun fight for us specifically because
a lot of these games have reached time
control or are about about to finish but
this one is far from we have a position
in which white
is uh
has a little bit of a space advantage
because of the positioning of some of
his pieces the knight on c4 is a little
bit more advanced than the knight of c6
and these pawns give you more access to
this to the center than what the black
does but
it's still a symmetrical pawn structure
black has his chances on the king side
as well
and even though i would probably take
the white side i'm not really sure how
strong
his advantage is in this position
yeah you can see that a lot of the light
scores are weak the more i look at it
the more i'm realizing maybe white is
actually a lot better than i thought he
was
because you can you can start improving
with bishop e2
and the moment you trade this bishop for
uh the one on e6 i don't know if i want
to do it now or later but the moment i
do that it's very difficult to cover all
of the light square weaknesses that
black has settled himself with on the
king side whereas white's light square
weaknesses are difficult to reach
um it's they're just not so easy to
attack for any piece it's not the queen
but the queen has no support the knight
so c6 and e7 are very far from reaching
some of these key squares that one seems
to be a very uh deep strategical battle
but one that is going completely off the
rails is the game between uh a dragoon
camille and uh sam savion because we
left it off after a4 and it felt like
white is just simply taking or it felt
like this move was missed by a black and
the computer actually agrees white is
completely winning but there are still
some complications that he needs uh to
maneuver around and after a4 g takes h4
a takes b5 now you are getting uh this
exchange but at the same time black
species are invading your position
knight to f3 came on the board of course
you cannot take on if on f3 with the
rook because after queen to d1 you're
going to lose the rook after king to g2
i have the move h3 forcing the uh king
off uh the path off the defense of the
rook on f3 and this is going to be big
big problems for you of course the funny
part is yes i i this i agree with you
until i saw that the engine bar actually
thinks white's winning in this position
yes you're right you're right actually
uh rook takes f3 might have been an
option as well actually might have been
the correct move
one of the correct moves
so rook takes f3 is indeed one of the
correct moves that actually makes a lot
of sense because after queen to d1
yes and now we see after h3 you take on
h3 queen takes f3
and you just go for the end you just go
for the anger you take on f3 you take on
f3 you take on a6 yep and the problem is
that i am up you're going to take on uh
e4 but now if we count the pawns first
of all i am a pawn up but i also have
this incredibly dangerous close to
promotion pawn all the way to a7 you're
going to have uh to give a lot of
resources to the defense of the
promotion of the a pawn and this is just
a very very difficult end game for uh
black uh
this funny kind of interesting that he
decided against this line because it
also feels quite easy to calculate yeah
the thing is the thing is you calculate
it out to uh knight f3 rook f3 queen d1
is forced this is no surprise and it
simplifies the position also yeah the
thing is you're up you're up a um maybe
rook takes f3 was something that he uh
he was afraid of i mean you can
certainly see how you can be afraid of
this move right but
you only need a couple more moves
because after queen here you cannot go
because of bishop square but i'm gonna
force you on the dark square you don't
have a choice um if you go there queen
h5 and again
uh you can go king g8 it's your only
remaining light square but i'm gonna
force you into a dark square with a move
queen g6 either on h8 or on f8 and then
either bishop to b2 or bishop to a3 is
going to come with a check and you're
going to lose
the queen so yes it seems like he missed
a huge opportunity also
king to g2 was good too
king to g2 was fine as well and this
seems to be winning after h3 just simply
continue picking up your points and it
doesn't seem like you get enough
compensation for all the material
instead of that he played this move king
to h1 and he missed an incredible move
and that is the move rook to f5
okay now do you understand this move is
aimed specifically at giving support for
this knight to retreat all the way to g5
so that i can attack this pawn on e4 you
cannot take if you take knight to g5 you
go king to g1 i go knight to h through
knight to h3 and that is a checkmate on
the board so rook to f5 was missed
let's see what he played rook to f5 was
played
bishop to b2 came on the board makes it
that's a great move f5 i have to say
knight to g5
rook takes f5 this is the current
position on the board we're probably
going to see something along the lines
of take on e4 king to g1 you have to you
have to think about the pawn right f5
but this is a mess keeping some pressure
on this rook on b1 you don't have time
to force the queen trade with queen to
d4 first of all also f3 is coming on the
board so you have to go rook to c1 by
the way let's look at the clock
bishop takes e4 we have two minutes and
30 seconds for oh man uh a dragoon three
minutes and 41 seconds for sam savion
with sam savion definitely on the attack
yeah this is turning around to go 12
more moves
is turning around but it's also wild
completely wild so let's take a look at
some knights the stakes i i was
wondering if i could throw in the move
queen c3 because it is you know your
checkmate threat i guess yes yes uh you
check king f1
ack when d3 trades the queens and wins
the work that's very unfortunate but but
th this is probably the best uh solution
that works it's a draw at the end and
you just go for a draw and and do i have
time to take on a6 probably no no no no
no no no no no no because then i just
retrieve my knight and then bishop
catches the pawn
so you take on h3 and
i take and this this became surprisingly
take i take you take
and then i'm going to put the bishop
here i'm going to
catch your pawn and there's no way to
make any progress it actually just makes
a trivial silly draw
very easy draw wow
but but finding this is actually kind of
hard because even after the move bishop
b2 right oh sorry so after the move uh e
takes f5 you don't actually know if
you're worse no right
you might still think you're you're
doing okay and actually sam has not
played the move ef5 that surprises me a
little bit through he started with
knight h3 the engine thinks it's
horrible because lost
completely lost because engines so
what's the difference king f1 is the
only move on the board okay so what if
you
take here now you go here i guess the
difference is i don't have some kind of
knight f3 trickeries probably the knight
was supposed to land on f3 in the
previous variation so let's try to
understand that if you take rook to c1
no actually he's just gonna have three
anyway he wants to take on b5 the
computer
if you go knight to f3 then no you're
just worse fire this computer i don't
believe it get out of here get out of
your engine none of this makes any sense
but apparently here black has
compensation and we throw in the knight
on h3 you don't so now this is the
position we currently have on the board
okay knight to h3 king sorry um
knight to h3 king to f1 bishop takes f5
keeping contact with aircon b1 you have
to do something about that
probably you're going to go to c1 right
i guess i mean i don't have that many
other moves i i would be somewhat
attempted to look at rook e1 and d5
makes a lot of sense you're getting
ready to penetrate on this diagonal and
potentially give the checkmate oh man
i'm a little scared of both sides here
uh now he just takes on a6
says okay i see a pawn i'll take it i
don't believe you have any sort of
checkmates no th this is so scary this
looks so scary alejandro if i would be
looking at this position with how much
time on the clock two minutes and
counting and the other thing i'm looking
at is how the trade queens are making
yes and we do see resignation by misha
antipov against hans neiman we did
expect that one let's go back to uh the
game in question
yeah no i mean this one is wild um and
in fact maybe we can look on your board
because i do want to see um these
players right now i i want to see what
their reaction is if we can get i don't
know if we have cameras on this specific
board uh but he's actually thinking with
the bishop on f5 to me
there we have it
to me this is the more logical version
like if you throw a knight h5 not h3
it's so you can go queen d5 right and if
you're gonna go queen d5 you're going to
take with the bishop one minute and 30
seconds and counting and we see camille
i think he's restless right now sam
feels that he has counter play you know
sam feels confident he sees that queen
on d5 coming there's a little
psychological effect on this too right
you you're down to a minute and you have
the initiative here as black you know
that he's not going to be getting out of
time pressure any time soon and you went
from a lost position
i'm pretty sure sam knew he was lost
to suddenly chances right you just don't
know what's going on in another games
result that we expected jj ali morani
has defeated robert kungoski uh jumps
back to 50
uh with the craziest bunch of 50 results
possible but let's keep up on this game
alejandro what do you do right now as as
white do you start calculating rook to
c1 and allowing the queen to come to d5
i mean
i would tell you what i wouldn't do why
would why wouldn't you do i would i
wouldn't leave this hanging he played
king e1 yeah but you can't take it
you can can you take it you can let's
look at that so he's left the rook on b1
hanging and we're wondering why you
cannot take this okay you can go check
takes c6
definitely cannot go this way no because
this one gets checkmated here on g7 so
you have to go to um f8 and here
i
uh
i mean i could take on h3 but that's not
what i'm looking for
by the way i don't think he took i'm
pretty sure he played queen to d5 he
played queen d5 anyway but this looks
like a worse version right because i can
get the rook to d1
can i get the rook to d1 no no
because queen h1
is made on c2 anyway well in fact you
can't you can yes all right queen here
king d2
check
i'm not sure about the end game after
queen e2
what else you cannot go to c1 you get
checked yeah this is
one is checkmate and this i assume just
doesn't work right pick up your either
your bishop or your probably the rook
the rook you don't have attacks so you
take you go queen e2
oh my god someone should calculate all
right i guess i take take and i go check
can go somewhere
i'm assuming that this
is too slow but i don't know why yet
i guess i just take on a6 right yeah oh
so i guess you take on b5 here
or do you take on d1 you take on d1
i have to take on d1
this pawn takes on if you take on g3
then i take on a6 and this bomb promotes
and this one doesn't
because the bishop just comes back to
the defense right
yes yes so you can't actually play hg
but you can play a b
and then i guess you take right why not
but this is winning for black
i mean i'm up two points
that's a lot of points it's a lot of
puns right i i stick it out on d5 and
bring the king should be with me
yeah okay he played rook c1 so
maybe this is maybe because of that he
played rook c1 that way there's no
skewer on g4
what a mess
i i think you have to take the time to
take on b5 right
just like that well the problem with
these lines right now i can go on c3 i
can also go with king queenie too and
since you don't pick up the rook
um
i mean i'm at least okay though maybe i
should be playing for a win with king c3
yeah
i don't know what a complete mess and if
i take here
white surprisingly has zero checks
no but i feel i have to
no but i don't have the
a way to get my knight involved into uh
into play because whenever i go knight
to f2 you go queen to g5 yeah this
knight is actually doing an important
job on h3 which is to hold the g5 square
so here queen g5 check
we don't really know how strong this is
but it feels that if you lose this
coordination for one move
that
you will get in trouble so rook c1 is
played let's just put that on the the
current position on the board
uh rook c1
played
and
this position is just a mess i really
don't know what is the time situation
here 41 seconds for dragoon and one
minute and 20 seconds and counting for
sam savion and a lot of
very difficult decisions ahead for both
of both sides it's such a difficult
position to play both of these players
have very very difficult it's kind of
amazing that they left themselves so
little time to play such a complex
situation and we have with us uh a
victor of today's round uh jj alimorandi
but we're gonna have him analyze this
position with us because we're running
out of time and we don't want to break
the
flow of the game but jj welcome welcome
to the studio congrats on your win a
very topsy-turvy game
uh topsy-turvy tournament i would say
yes definitely uh but a nice nice to
pick up away tell us your first instinct
on what's going on here in the position
on the board a takes b5 boom
that was played yeah yeah
wow and g6 h4
yeah it looks very unclear
but
well the question is right now is the
white king getting checkmated
is the black king getting checkmated
that is also a very good question
um
let's say it's equal yeah that's the
practical answer it's always equal
is this what i think by the way you are
definitely correct because this is what
i teach them
the engine says zero zero zero zero zero
i mean when both sides don't have time
these positions can get super
complicated like yesterday i was hoping
for something like this and i was
actually lost so
and i thought it could be double edged
and if the engine is giving zeros i
guess it's it can go either way but
so it's equal objectively but who has
the better side of equality right now is
the question
from my perspective is
white because right now it doesn't feel
like you have a good way to create
anything around my king i really like
this move gtx h4 by the way yeah it's a
very practical move right you just get
rid of hg forever but more importantly
it gives the g3 square to this queen and
suddenly you can imagine many variations
in which queen g3 queen g7 will be
devastating i actually haven't seen
which lines but actually queen g3 is a
devastating threat because king f8 i
have bishop a3
and i think i start
giving you checkmate
and i assume that if you ever have to
interpose the bishop that it's not
actually on its ideal diagonal although
who knows maybe it is okay so right now
i guess we should go with queen to h1
play king d2 queen h2 and now if you go
to c3 i'm going to take advantage of the
fact that you in fact took on h4 and
opened up that diagonal so now my queen
on h2 supports uh this retreat with the
knight to f4 so if you want to go queen
e2 knight f4 you mean
no no if you go queen to e2 i'm going to
start looking for some extra tracks
maybe queen to d6
queen d6 maybe
no it's it is really weird because
i actually feel i'm getting kind of
mated here
but
so if you go king to c3 i think
e4 you know i was thinking this is
checkmate but then i realized it wasn't
and it actually don't see it at all
knight f4 maybe knight f4 maybe you just
bring the other piece to the attack i
like d3 yeah yeah it's coming to d3
yeah this is over yeah so king c3 on the
board uh this is the current position
does he have b4 here
and then queen b2
does he have the
that's a very good question right
b4 check
you might as well take what else well he
definitely has that and the question is
uh does white has a group takes seven
takes seven yeah there's no more this is
your only chance right there's no no
check on the g file there's this check
doesn't really help me because queen g7
at the very least by bishop g4 is also
good but rook takes c7
and
what a mess and it the evaluation hasn't
really changed yeah the evaluation is
this is a mess and
and we continue he actually didn't play
before he actually just brought the
knight back
also makes sense but it allows queen g1
yeah it does allow queen g1 with the
simplification take it
i think you have to take it right take
the queen trade i think you have to take
the queen trade
i mean this king is just becoming a bit
too vulnerable the knight is finally
joining the fray with the move knight d5
uh check on the next move by the way uh
knight to f4 was played with three
seconds on the clock
so
again big decisions you need to allow
yourself to have more time on the clock
that's the practical and i i think the
lower this gets on time the more likely
you are to play queen g1 and so you want
yeah you have almost sure you'll play
queen g1
he has to
yeah i think yeah quincy one played
takes i you have to take and i guess you
take
and
you still have a few moves to make time
control but
there's no real danger here for white at
all then the minor piece is not gonna
made you the question is do you have
winning chances here well the position
got simplified we're going to let the
players think about this one i'm sure
they're going to reach time control
without any problems but jj let's go
into your game because
you saw this scandinavian on the board
and you immediately launched an attack
with b4 was that preparation or like
no honestly i was just in the mood to
play some gambits today the usual yeah
regardless of what opening it was and
when he played the scandinavian i was a
little
annoyed that i didn't get what i wanted
so i was like okay let's just at least
have some fun and played before okay now
tell me did alejandro teach you this
i would never teach such moves i mean it
was an over-the-board decision okay to
be honest because i was like if i play
the main lines it's gonna be boring so
i'll just at least have some fun let's
go for the kill i like it yeah
yeah and it's if you got everything you
wanted out of the opening and g6 i don't
understand like
uh maybe it makes sense but to me it was
a bit awkward but yeah and it seems like
you got almost a winning position
also f6 was shocking but like i don't
know if i
had something better i think i played
like h1 queen e2 it was a bit too slow
um
probably makes not
much sense but
i don't know i thought it was safe to
play king h1 actually bishop this is a
very nice win but bishop jade is winning
i know that you never look at these
moves i looked at it i just didn't see
how it wins
because you have to think with the king
right yes if you take with the rook then
you have bishop eight six and then seven
knight g5 right yeah nf king here 96
knight d6 yeah
so
what happens if you take with the king
in this position
yeah i don't know i couldn't see it so i
was like
if i don't see it i shouldn't give up my
light squared bishop i'm just going to
cheat yes please yeah engine says bishop
h6 plus six
bishop
i mean yeah but like how do you
guarantee it during a game i guess
yeah it makes sense yes when you know it
when it's plus six
yeah i i guess if black has no moves
here right it just paralyzes paralyzed
completely and even this doesn't help
you
and i guess the key point is that if you
go queen to h5 you have knight xf6 or oh
this is nice yeah this is nice yeah you
just even if you take and you take this
black if i saw this i would play it for
sure yeah and
if you uh play king takes here and here
as christian was mentioning then knight
f6
it's a pretty nice line uh black's
getting pretty much mated in every
variation
yeah this is checkmate for sure
and sticks with the part and if you take
with the pawn
then i think you just go check pick up
the rook and pick up just a rough
position and then you take on b7 at the
end although you have i can take on c8
now and you can think of the idea i just
went over you can take on c8 and just
win a work on at least the rook
and call it a day yeah that would have
been nice i could have been done like
two hours ago right but yeah
but you wouldn't be here with us in the
studio so that's why you took your sweet
time
yeah and i mean i was thinking these
moves were logical but apparently not so
logic goes out the window when you talk
to computers
yeah
uh when were you absolutely sure that
you were winning
uh pretty much never until the last move
i think
like he was getting low on time so i
knew he was going to blend or something
and then around here i thought i was
having sufficient counter play for like
the two pawns and i was confident he was
gonna blunder he had no time so and he
did blunder but
not the best
technique but
i mean with no time also i probably
don't need
the best technique just wanted to be
practical and that's it
well certainly a nice victor how do you
rate your tournament so far i mean it
has a lot of ups and downs i'm not like
super happy about it but also like at
least i'm playing some fun chess so it's
it's entertaining at least some fun
chess for sure well thank you for
joining us uh jj certainly a fun game to
watch it did keep us captivated for the
better part of half an hour here in the
studio uh as soon as we started the
program
uh congratulations thank you
all right let's move on uh we have some
results in
the b group
as uh ilya nishnik did draw uh darius
fearts alexander mandu jeffrey shong
uh
actually i think we're going to have
uh hans for an interview in just a
second oh very good i haven't talked to
him here enough
and meanwhile on the other hand at all
on the show that's true
uh we also have the game between aaron
huckabee and
ray robson in which white
could say they still have a minuscule
pool because of the
because of the space and yada yada but
you expect this to end in a draw almost
always
and
we have this this titanic battle
between camille dragoon and sam sevien
and i think they reach time they reach
time control
it feels pretty dryish but
it's definitely white but it's white
who's trying right and perhaps
perhaps in a practical game you do lose
this once in a while oh yeah yeah
actually more perhaps more than once in
a while but somebody that must be
thrilled with their performance today is
hans nieman who defeated mishantipo with
the black pieces
hans welcome to the studio tell us a
little bit about your tournament so far
topsy-turvy you started off with a very
exciting game against ray robson you
were winning then you were losing then
it ended up in a draw then you won a
game then you lost the game and now you
finally won with the black pieces tell
us a little bit about your tournament
and how you assess it
i think it's a pretty bad event
from
result perspective but um i think that
the results have not been reflective of
my play i think in as you mentioned in a
few specific critical moments things
sort of
didn't go my way
like in this robson game
um you know i i am in time pressure
missed a win and in a few other games
some results have flipped
so i think i've actually been playing
very well i'm very happy with my play
i'm just not that happy with how i've
managed my nerves in the critical
moments but i think in general i've
shown
pretty good chess especially today and
against my winning winning slenderman as
well absolutely today was a very
clinical performance especially in the
end game let's take a look at that game
when did you feel like your opponent is
starting to er
um that's a very fancy vocabulary word
christian i think i'm glad that you've
been studying
um i almost couldn't understand that one
um utd education right there thank you
yeah well it's but you know where
yeah um however if you are ambitious
about your chess stay away from college
i'll i'll put that last thing in anyways
um yeah so i had this you know you see
they got this d5 idea this was a nice
little opening tidbit but uh you know
when i had like 50 minutes against
uh 30 seconds in a much better position
i started to feel that he went wrong but
um yeah i think this opening idea was
actually played
um it was actually for the first time or
in the second time actually
um it was in a classical game was played
um robs dragoon against robson and he
won that game to show this idea but this
is like a so prepared for this game
i assume that he was sort of aware of it
because of you know following the other
games but he didn't really react
properly here
and um
in relation to the other game i'm going
to nerd out here you know some people
might just
think i'm think i'm not uh
might i get this but in this position
you know with the bishop on b5 and the
rook and i phase transposing to the game
so here you know
this is sort of you know we were
debating after the game whether it's an
improvement um but having the rookie i
thought it was an improvement especially
after after he took and played knight e3
which is not really the most precise so
after bishop takes bishop takes uh
there's the same position in the robson
game but the rook was in faith this
wasn't b5 so from a logical perspective
one concluded rick on the eighth is
good like
i guess he disagreed but uh i thought
that this is just a fine improvement so
this was certainly winning the opening
battle and then i think i just
it was a clinical uh positional game
after that
um yeah you can go through it but yeah
so here so this is queen d5 uh 97 this
is i saw this move and i was like did i
blunder
and then i realized you know queen b3
ab3 i mean b3 i have king f7
so this position king f7 takes king f6
was just really interesting because uh
he you know it looks like white
could be better because this there's
some weird tension and some concrete
issues with the weak c7 pawn and also
there's to defend this pawn there's also
the f3 break and then if you defend
rookie seven like i put in the game this
is before break it's a lot of you know
nuances and
weird ideas here
but i think the most important thing you
didn't really understand is that if i
play the move g5 he's just never going
to be better um
and
after rookie 7
b4 g5 bishop d2 rookie eighth i've sort
of gotten rid of these concrete issues
and now i'm ready to just uh play on the
king side and think like you know okay
from all
general perspectives like my king is is
very good his king is bad um my position
can improve much more than
in his scan with just extending on the
king side so it's not really clear he's
just a bit a bit too weak um
so
yeah this is where things are started to
feel optimistic um so okay b5 knight e7
c4
um
f4
well i didn't play four i can't even
remember
b6 yes i know you played f4 thank you
thank you yes now
yeah so so before this is another so
here if you go back like before f3
um this is where you know okay so if i
remember he had like 15 minutes 353 he
has six
and um
if he doesn't play f3 he can sort of
wait
and he's probably not like lost but he's
just going to get slowly you know
squeezed
um as i see carl says you know like
squeezing some orange juice you know
and uh pineapple juice
pineapple juice you know and and just
you know you guys are shooting on twitch
i gotta like get some clips for you so
you guys can boost your viewership and
get the hikara watching the stream like
i'm doing you guys a favor right here
you know just even mentioning kikara
will get you
know a lot more viewers i know you guys
have been waiting for me just to come on
and do this interview because you just
needed some content you know so i will
give you your value there we go
um
so
you know he could have just so here's
this is a thing because he gets low on
time and he's like okay i got we gotta
go we gotta go he just starts
blitzing and and going for really risky
stuff and everything just collapsed um
so i can if there's a critical moment i
will stop yeah so c5 knight d4
okay yeah so if if am i lost here is the
question
because so here i made a little bit of a
calculated risk i was like this guy's
got two minutes
i see what he should do
i just don't think he's going to do it
with with uh that much of the clock so
after rookie 8 rookie 8
he's supposed to take on b6 or what yeah
takes on b6
knight f3 mata iii and i was like if if
he plays this with two minutes on the
clock h1 maybe
i would i just i just i i submitted 20
years king h1 ricky's two rookie two or
three two gets me so king f2 i
calculated king f2
i kingdom two as well and i was like
okay take some b6
let's see seven i guess and then
i was like okay knight c4
and rick c8 c1 rook c1 rook c1
knight d6 and apparently
after b6 i just
maybe i'm just lost
get a calculation
so i was like i saw this but i was like
nah he's not going to play like and i
saw this at maybe like 15 seconds but i
was like just no she's not going to play
so i was like
i think i'm just lost yeah no but roxy
rook c8 i don't really know why you're
lost but i'm going to pretend like ricky
won for q1
you know what
knight b7 knight b7 yeah
and then
it does look a bit dangerous okay maybe
i'm not lost
maybe i'm not lost you know my
calculation wasn't really in the past
my conclusion was there's no way and if
i lose this i lose this but if i don't
go for this i'm not going to win the
game you know so you got to risk it for
the biscuit you know have you learned
that phrase christian i know that i know
that one yeah you have okay
okay
uh so
you know he didn't go for this
yeah i'm i'm cheating a little bit but
it is precisely because he has to go to
either f2 or g2 and g2 slightly worse
because it gets it allows rookie two
later
is that you actually have this check uh
on on e4 instead of going through c4
and
uh this is apparently an important tempo
because well the b6 doesn't come with a
threat
uh so you could you after b6 what do i
play
uh b6 it's it's not it says point eight
after room uh rookie three rookie three
ah
rookie three rook b3 okay get behind the
phones so you know my instinct
was you know just full cent you know if
you're a fan of enough boys um
which i don't think any of you guys so
much culture
prime culture yeah
you know i just think you should just
full send it for the boys eh we'll send
it for the boys yeah my god i have never
felt so old like i feel it right now i
am just trying to help you guys get more
viewers you know i'm a nice guy
you've never had a happy dad
oh the happy dance you know if i was old
enough
i'd be drinking happy dads
we made it to day seven without going
crazy but this is the end guys we are we
are finito we are done all right hans
good job good win uh
good stuff
thank you also please look at the logos
yeah there we go if i'm farming content
yeah shout out to my sponsors trustable
24.
excellent chess 24 great company and are
going to be working for them anytime
soon
yeah um i'm a brand ambassador you know
i am doing some streaming for them i'll
be playing in the next tour event i
believe so doing some streaming
promotional stuff
growing the beautiful game of chess
and you know in a cool stylish way with
weird shirts and buzz cuts oh that's for
the boys for the boys my mom was doing
that before all right
thank you hans for joining us always an
entertaining character certainly with an
autopsy turvy tournament and let's try
to finish up on what's going on with
today's round
all right uh we have ray robson against
aaron jacobian as i mentioned uh black
white is better in this position but
it's apparently better than i thought in
initially i actually thought that white
has to be better in this position let me
explain a little bit why
this knights on e3 and c4 control a lot
of squares is knights on c6 and e7 are a
bit awkward and you can see also that
there are some weaknesses on the light
squares around the black's king that
being said symmetrical pawn structure
not that many weaknesses to attack i
really expected this to be more equal
than apparently it is because even after
only a few moves the engine really does
not like black's position
and i think that white has very good
chances to actually keep improving uh
his
his position with the knights
specifically in the knight on
here coming to here and maybe
g4 knight f5 force you to take and then
target the pawn on g7 originally i
wasn't sure that's going to be enough to
win because you don't really want to
trade one night when you have this much
space
uh
but perhaps it's more dangerous than i
thought christian uh more updates no
absolutely that one definitely feels at
least from a practical perspective quite
dangerous for uh black because of the
lack of space but uh one a game that
seems to be going uh white's uh
direction is the one between camille
dragoon and sam sevillan which we were
having our eyes on and we were saying at
this point that at least from a
practical perspective it seems like
black is going to have a very difficult
defense ahead of himself and that is
exactly what is happening because bishop
to f3 came on the board rook to c5 b4
and right now this pawn is going to be
lost you have to focus as black on ways
to find a counter play on the king side
given to you by the h pawn and this is
exactly what he's doing rook to c4
knight to g6 rook takes b4
i'm looking at this position i'm seeing
this past pawn on the b file
the rook is a great i'm going to be able
to potentially hold on uh to this pawn
with my bishop landing on e5 potentially
i i i think white has great chances to
win this one so
this one i'm going to give it to uh
dragoon let's see what's happening in
the b group because
the big clash between uh tournament
leader chris rapko and christopher youth
seems to be going
as it was an hour ago as well
christopher's away but i feel he did
have some better options at one point so
let's see i think we left it somewhere
around here when this knight landed on
g4 and it was ready to go to e3 which in
fact happened we uh saw this position
and now black has all the time in the
world to create his attack potentially
double up on the e file and then start
start pushing his pawns on the queen
side
what white is lacking at this point in
the game is any sort of counter play
you cannot try to uh
open up the position on the king side
because that's just going to help black
you cannot
open the position on the queen side
because well the structure just doesn't
allow you to do so this pawn on a5
coupled with the action of the bishop b4
is just keeping the position very
compact on this side and this one is not
looking great for white let's see what
happened queen to f6
bishop to h3 you see white is just
trying to find moves and he just doesn't
have a lot of them king to h1 king to g1
and black has a lot of ways in which he
can improve his position and this is
exactly what we see b6 queen to c6 rook
to e6 queen to d7 some desperation but
the lonely queen cannot do much i have
so
much firepower with my queen on f6 the
rooks doubled up on the e-5 and this is
the key
uh piece in the position the knight on
e3 which gives black a tremendous
advantage and right now h4 rook to f4
rook to d6 we have this position
h takes g3 is on the board i'm seeing
this queen potentially landing on e5
putting on more pressure on a white
spawn structure
if you have to go rook to f4 i mean your
pieces are so passive as white all i
have to do is figure out a way
to include this bishop into the attack
all of all all of black's pieces are in
included into the attack except the
bishop b4 if i managed to put it on d6
and put some pressure on this diagonal
target this rook on f4 as well as the
weakness on g3 well your position is
going to collapse so this is the only
plan that i have as black in the
position this is what i should be
focusing on specifically for that reason
probably rook to f6
just seems to be winning this
game of course white is going to have to
find some sort of counter chances
um
related to the idea of bishop to d5 the
queen is already on a8 potentially
trying to target the king via the g8
square so
let's wait and see but it definitely
seems to be going christopher's way 19
minutes on the clock for him 29 minutes
for chris repka this one is going to go
down to the wire but it seems like maybe
the leader of the b group might go down
in this round alejandro still a lot to
play for i think if you are a fan of
chris a rap guy don't worry there's
still plenty of hope there uh let me
take a look at what happened in the
mishra game against al-shamri devadi in
that game we thought that black had a
terrible position but somehow elshin put
up incredible defense and kudos to him
finding a lot of important moves
including
this move b5 which the more we saw it
the less we liked it but the engines
thought it was absolutely fine for black
and so did alshan apparently going into
this position and actually the very
clever move bishop e7 in this position
instead of something else we were
looking at i think knight f6 and the
point is that if you take with the
bishop on b5 i think
i will have the resource of bishop d8 in
this position where the bishop is
attacking the rook and it's the only
defender of the bishop on b5 and this
will force these simplifications which
again a little bit surprisingly to me
don't really lead anywhere but remember
the black is temporarily up
it's not apple pawn but
will regain one of these pawns on b4 d5
so you actually have to take something
but you can only take one thing either
on h7 or the d6 and in either case it
seems that black is doing actually just
fine
so bishop e7 is perhaps a very clever
practical move even though the engine
thinks knight f6 is more precise
and we got into this position
kind of chaotic with low time for both
sides where white needs to advance the
pawn to g3 and move the king to g2
because this rook comes very annoying on
the first rank
g6 rook k7 was played
knight f6 and somehow
you know black got real counter play and
it went for the immediate move e4
uh a pretty committal 41st move but at
this point you already had plenty of
time to think about it he actually
thought uh like 30 minutes on this move
and after the move f takes
e4 i expect to move f3 i don't know so i
don't see why else you ever do this i'm
surprised it's not on the board honestly
f3 king takes f3 rook takes f1
where you're up a piece
but i'm not sure who's playing for a win
because you have this annoying move e5
um
you could keep your pieces with 98 i
think but you really don't want to be
playing that
you want to take on d5 i think you take
here rook b1
and i think this might also
more or less fizzle out to a draw
although white is on the better side of
it so you take on e7 right now i think i
think the clever moves to play b6 so if
you take on e7 i don't take the pawn on
e7 i mean leave this one alive i
actually take on b b5 and i don't think
you ever defend this successfully yeah
i mean you can play bishop
but i have rook before i start attacking
the bishop i start getting behind the
pawn i could even go like b3 rook e3 i
think that tactically rookie is even
better yeah i i think at this point it's
just a choice of uh so it seems probably
we're going to have something along the
lines of white ghost e8 because picks up
the pawn on h7 and we're going to play
rook and bishop and a pawn against rook
and knight which is probably going to be
a technical draw right and so just to
point out that the the only line that
really does scare me is this one with b6
uh you
you don't actually give up the
the piece immediately now you don't take
the piece immediately and the point is
that i defend my opponent if you take
with the knight this is a check suddenly
this is a check and that rook returns to
b7 that one is dangerous and i think
this is just winning
uh so
perhaps still some work to be done by
al-shan who's maybe realizing that the
position is not so easy
and kudos again to mishra because this
the sequence of fe4 if you saw all the
way to e5 it's on d6 it's it's a really
really nice sequence and by the way of
course moradia body has other options as
well as you were mentioning knight to e8
to preserve the knight he needs to
calculate he needs to calculate pretty
accurately in this position i think it's
a it's a tall order well alejandro uh
another very exciting round another very
exciting interview we have to get the
comments on the show a bit more often
we're going to expand our viewership
with all these cultural references i i
do like how he threw both chest 24 and
he carved out yeah
everybody
have it all boys uh but yes let's uh see
where we stand in this round round
number seven a very important round for
the standings two uh three games have
finished in uh the a group we have hans
who won a very important game against
misha antipov who is just simply
struggling in this event jeffrey strong
against alex lederman and darius zavier
versus ilya nishnik have finished in a
draw and how about the big group
in the big group we have more games to
be played ali morandi beating hungaski
is the only result we have so far and
everything else is actually kind of up
in the air uh just very quickly going to
say that raja hardship i think is a
favorite to draw against
uh sarganin but it's certainly a lot of
work together a lot of work to do
sometimes i'm certainly the favorite
there and i think the same can be said
about this game between armand mikhail
with the black pieces who's pushing
against titus ramavichis but we also
think it's closer to a draw no i'm not
so sure about that one uh and we as we
expected mishra to play against el
sheimerybody for quite a while and chris
repka
with an uncomfortable defense but so far
he's still holding on against
christopher yu well alejandro
penultimate round tomorrow we are
getting closer and closer to uh the
culmination of this event i'm very
excited is going to be an exciting round
don't forget join us uh on youtube and
twitch for this broadcast the games
start at 1 pm central time our show is
going to start at 3 30 pm central time
at the same place at the same time
tomorrow also you can reach us on social
media at
spring chess classic until tomorrow i'm
grand master christian kirilla
with grand master alejandro ramirez and
we will be seeing you guys tomorrow
please join us and we'll see you
tomorrow 3 30.
so
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited